last night it was uh what they're
calling climate night for all of the
terminally unfunny late night
shows
um all of the all the late night hosts
all the jimmies and then seth meyers
they all they all got together and
on their own individual shows or or
together all all at once they all
decided to raise awareness about the
climate so
just more hilarious comedy from these
guys let's watch james corden and seth
meyers introduced this concept really
funny stuff listen james and i are
joining forces along with other late
night hosts for climate night one night
where we put aside our intense white hot
rivalries and come together to raise
awareness for the vast effects the
climate is having on our lives and the
things we can do to help there's a lot
of misinformation out there to combat
and there are initiatives in congress we
can support and countless ways that you
can reduce your carbon footprint because
this climate crisis affects the whole
world whether you're in new york like i
am or in the uk where james is uh well
sorry
actually seth i'm i'm in california
that's a california accent
wow
well no i'm so no i'm i'm from the uk
but i i shoot my show in california
i think that's something you should make
clear in the opening credits
who's watching this i i don't i don't
believe it
i know the ratings are pretty low i i
don't believe that any person who's who
is sitting down and deciding to watch
seth meyers who i want to know who
if you're watching this right now if
you're watching this and you have made
the decision in your life at any point
to actually sit down and watch seth
meyers
who's never made a funny joke in his
life he's been a comedian
for i don't know decades
never said anything funny not once
so i want you to explain yourself i want
so i i'm sincere about this i want an
explanation
even if the ratings are low they still
allegedly
have probably hundreds of thousands of
people who choose to spend their night
watching this kind of stuff
was any of that funny
was that a laugh track in the background
were there
was the audience at gunpoint
nothing funny happening there
and of course increasingly they're not
even trying to be funny because it's all
about the the left-wing agenda we also
have jimmy kimmel who's another guy's
never
and i'm not just saying this because
they're a bunch of left-wing hacks
although they are
it's theoretically possible for a
left-wing hack to be funny sometimes but
these people never are
jimmy kimmel had
another hilarious comedy bit
bringing on climate scientists to scold
all of us for you know not doing enough
to protect the climate let's watch
hello again we're climate scientists
real climate scientists not actors five
years ago we came on jimmy's show we
told you climate change is real that
it's undeniably caused by human activity
that it's going to be catastrophic and
that we weren't with you
totally not with you i thought we made
that clear but now it's five years later
the globe is hotter hurricanes are
stronger droughts are worsening coral
reefs are dying wildfires are raging and
floods are even
floodier
so we're back with a new message and we
really hate to say this
but
we told you so
we told you so
we told you we'd be by climate change
and now we are just like we said
these people really make me root for
climate change
at this point
though climate change is gonna it's
gonna kill all of humanity okay well
good then
um
oh man
this is comedy ladies and gentlemen
that's what that's comedy right there
and of course meanwhile they're saying
oh we told you so we because this is
what they're doing this is the problem
they run into
these chicken littles with the climate
that they have been
before even the phrase climate change
entered common parlance
because people that are as old as me i
mean i can remember
when i was in school
and i heard about uh the ozone layer the
big hole in the ozone later layer that
was that was it was only was being
destroyed
um we don't hear so much about that
anymore
you know you heard about uh they're
gonna cut all the trees down we won't
have oxygen anymore
there was i could actually vividly
remember a point about third grade when
i when i went home from school one day
um rather distressed at the idea that
pretty soon all the trees are going to
be on it we're all going to suffocate
and i told that to my parents it's one
of the many times in my public school
career where my parents would have to
undo the brainwashing that had been
that i had been done um
so there was that and then also global
warming they talked about
before before before my time there was
they were worried about global cooling
and then they changed the global warming
and the thing is all of those claims
ozone layer
killing all the trees
global warming
those are pretty specific
and they made pretty specific and dire
predictions
that certainly by now in the year 2021
most of us should be dead by now and
should probably have all suffocated
and uh
but that's the problem is that it's too
specific and when you make a specific
claim
and a in a very specific prediction for
an end time
just as any modern religious
false prophet of the end times you know
there have been many religious cults
that have predicted
herald camping and so on it predicted
that uh this date or that date it's
going to be going to be the end of the
world the problem with doing that it's
it's more effective in the moment but
the problem is that um
that you you have set a standard
you've put a date on the calendar and
then what happens when you get to that
date and everything's fine
so now they've made it broader and now
we're talking about climate
what was the phrase that um
that's seth meyers or the other the
chubbier guy forget his name they use
for something like they they talk about
the risks of climate or the threat posed
by climate
the climate itself
now the climate itself is the problem
no
there's always been a climate and i'll
tell you something else there's also
always been climate change
that's what climates do by definition
that's the case
anywhere on earth at any point
on earth
anywhere in the universe
if you can find a planet that has a
climate it's going to
change so they broadened it though so
now it's climate change that covers
everything
and um what do you do about the fact
that they've repeatedly predicted the
end times and then we get to the end
time and we're still here
uh one thing you can do is just keep
pushing the date back and they're doing
that a little bit but they're also
saying oh you see we're we're basically
in the end times we told you so
meanwhile the rest of us are looking
around and saying i mean
i don't know we all seem to be pretty
pretty okay yeah there are hurricanes
and there's natural disasters we've
always had those
but other than that looking around i
mean life seems pretty normal we have
our seasons they come and go
everything seems okay
but of course if
seth meyers or any of these people if
they really
are concerned about climate change
one of the best things they can do how
much co2 how much energy
do they consume
by putting on
a tv show every single night
you would at least you're not going to
convince me
that i need to be terrified of climate
change but you will at least convince me
that maybe you take it seriously if you
were to say
impr in you know in reaction to climate
change and to do our part
and to make a real statement and to do
at least what we can
to stop our impending doom we're going
to shut down our show and we're not
going to do it anymore
because all these lights that we
that we keep on rolling the cameras
bringing all these people in you know
they all have to they drive in here some
of them fly in
we bring guests on and they they fly
you know burning all that jet fuel
so we're gonna shut it down we're not
gonna do the show anymore
that'd be a very good thing you could do
for the planet on on many levels
but at least if you were to do that then
i would believe that you take it
seriously but i don't
because as with covid
none of these people who are telling you
to be terrified of it
actually are themselves
and that ought to tell you something
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated